welcome to
pi data global 2021 my name is uh keep
sutter
and i'm in north carolina
in the us and
i'm going to be your moderator today for
this session
and for now i would like to introduce
our speaker for today who is amy
woody and she's going to talk about
love your neighbor more important love
your data scientist
reproducible data science the easy
better way
so um welcome uh amy to share your
screen and yeah thank you for
presenting today
thank you for having me i'm so glad to
be here
let's
dive
i'm not talking about reproducibility in
zoom i'm not talking about
reproducibility when speaking um
so let's get back and into
my quest for reproducibility in data
science
and especially data science workflows
this quest began a few years ago when i
was collaborating on some research for
how to evaluate the stability of text
embedding and dimension reduction
algorithms
as our wordpress progressed we started
wondering about how
to publish our methods reproducibly in a
way that we could still evolve our code
as a research move beyond our initial
results
that search led one of my collaborators
shell to attend the tutorial at pycon
2018 called down the rabbit hole a 101
on reproducible workflows with python
this was a great tutorial for us and it
delivered
fully leading us down the rabbit hole
from which we have yet to emerge
the start of my deep dive into
reproducibility came from a tool shell
brought back from that tutorial cookie
cutter data science
cookie cutter data science is a template
for your data science repos it gives an
excellent pre-built repo structure in
default project organization that is
flexible and thoughtful
as we start to use it
we realize that cookie cutter templates
were great starting places for shared
workflows
but we needed more than what cookie
cutter data science could offer
we needed a reproducible workflow that
helped to automate the grungy often
overlooked parts of our work
when we couldn't find existing tools to
do exactly what we wanted we started
writing scripts and adding them to our
fork of cookie cutter data science
as we got caught up in making our work
reproducible it turned into its own
research project that eclipsed the
project we started with
we started using a template for other
projects we started sharing with others
we used it as a base for team
collaboration and our everyday work even
for large workshops
this template was not only making our
work more reproducible but our shared
workflows more robust and efficient
the process of making our work
reproducible hasn't been easy in fact
the experience could be painstakingly
hard and sometimes even thankless even
for myself
during the challenging parts there were
moments where i second-guessed myself i
asked like why am i doing this
why am i bothering it's way harder to
make the research reliably reproducible
than to do the research itself
at the end of the day it would be easy
to just publish something that only
included our good copywork only included
the things that worked out really well
for us as a static snapshot of something
we did in the past it would be far
easier to leave out the ugly details of
our continuing work in progress and how
our work has continued to evolve
we could package up what we did nicely
neatly throw it on github just like we
used to do before we went down this
rabbit hole
but along the way i learned that there
were benefits i was seeing and
experiencing from reproducibility that
weren't just for the good of science or
for publishing our research
we were improving our workflows in all
sorts of ways i would have never
expected
we were saving time
improving our ability to collaborate and
building on the most important parts of
our work
our innocent fork of cookie cutter data
science started to take on a life of its
own and easy data was born
in this tutorial i'm going to be sharing
with you some of the lessons i've
learned on how to overcome the
challenges of making your work
reproducible
highlight some of the choices and
trade-offs that you can explicitly make
and help you to experience some of the
ways that we do this using easy data
easy data is a framework that helps you
to create reproducible environments
reproducible data and most importantly
reproducible workflows with ease and
without changing how you do your actual
data science work
now before we go any farther i want to
spend a moment and just reflect back on
what reproducibility is
what am i talking about when i say
reproducibility
well one of my favorite definitions is
this
if i gave you my laptop tomorrow could
you pick up where i left off today
this innocuous question hides a whole
bunch of thorny questions that are also
very innocuous sounding until you really
stop to think about it
i give you a laptop would you know where
to start
where would you go next
if anything was wrong in the
installation what would you need to do
to debug it
where would you find things
where would you get data
and
how would you even know what the data
was
would you know if the work was working
as expected the code was running the way
it was intended
and after all that work after you got
something running and working would you
even know what the point of my work was
now there are lots of reasons you might
care about reproducibility also lots of
reasons you might not care
but let's talk about a few of the ones
you might care about you're here after
all
one of the reasons is for science and i
love this reason it's great it's
important it's not the one we're going
to talk about today
there's lots out there you can learn
tons about reproducibility in science
and why it's so important and why it's
also really hard to do
but we'll leave that one on the shelf
for now
here are a couple other reasons you can
do more of the work that you love
you could choose how you work and spend
your time
and the one we'll focus on today is it
can help you with sharing your work and
collaborating with others
now let's talk about some common
reproducibility issues
as we go through the tutorial we're
going to be looking at what the issues
are then we're going to look at the ways
that we can solve them and how we do
that in easy data so let's talk
at the big scale zoomed all the way out
but what
the kinds of reproducibility issues are
that we're going to talk about today
there are three categories that
most reproducibility bugs fall into and
issues and i guarantee that you work
around these reproducibility issues
every day
your workarounds may take two minutes
here three minutes there
five minutes
and even worse with environment
management you're probably spending two
hours here
20 minutes there
45 minutes there
who knows
those are debugging nightmares so what
if you could avoid some of those things
here are some of the categories
first up
missing things things that are missing
missing things could be documentation
missing things could be missing state
like a notebook that had a cell deleted
that you need to be able to run the
whole notebook
and
one of the most common ones is
information that only lives in the
person's head who wrote the code
next up is high friction this is the
category of user experience there's all
sorts of things that are confusing
annoying
maybe too manual to bother with
so we just give up and we move on and we
use our little work around
the third category and one we won't get
into too much detail here but i want to
mention anyways is randomness
not everything is perfectly reproducible
even if we do everything to make it that
way and a lot of the times we attribute
things to randomness that maybe aren't
because we forget that we need to
control for it in the ways that we can
so since we have these reproducibility
issues they sound pretty simple things
that are missing
maybe things that are high friction but
once it gets in the way from us actually
solving these problems we have good
intentions we want to do things well we
want to do things reproducibly
oftentimes
my reasons and maybe yours are like this
i forgot about it i forgot to do it i
lost it
i didn't get to it maybe even i didn't
notice
sometimes we're not sure how to solve
that problem sometimes we've never
thought about it sometimes it's too much
work and sometimes reproducibility feels
like a discipline like eating that awful
food because it's somehow good for you
but today
i'd like to propose a solution
making better defaults
by making better defaults in your
workflow reproducibility doesn't have to
get in the way of how you do your data
science work in fact it can make it
easier and better
incorporating defaults that tackle the
most time and energy second
reproducibility bugs will pay back
dividends for your future self and
everybody who builds on your work
we're going to cover a bunch of default
better principles throughout this
tutorial and mostly as you're working
through it on your own
so i just want to highlight that these
are principles that
i'd like you to think about as ways to
incorporate into your work that you
don't have to incorporate
perfectly all the time
but if it's a default it's going to work
best most of the time there's always a
lot of diminishing returns on everything
that you do
so for this tutorial we're going to jump
right in now and start learning through
hands-on experience
to do that i'm going to be your guide
today on easy data quest for
reproducibility
this quest has six stages
at each stage we will discuss and cover
reproducibility issues ways that you can
think about it better
with default better principles and
examples of how we do it in easy data
this quest lets you dip your toes into
the water of reproducibility issues
associated with each of these questions
where do i start where do i go next what
do i need to install where do i find the
data does it work as expected
what's the purpose
this is going to be a quick whirlwind
tour
of some of the ways you can do this it's
by no need no means a deep dive into
reproducibility or easy data and how we
solve these problems itself
what can you expect
from this quest
this quest is about workflows and what
we do it's an embodied practice
it's more like learning a sport or
learning to play piano than sitting in a
lecture or listening to me talk
it will feel messy and maybe even
uncomfortable at times
but that's the point that's how we learn
you're going to be assigned to break out
groups of two or three people
and you're going to stay with the same
group throughout the quest
you'll be given instructions for how to
start at the beginning of each stage
you'll be expected to follow the quest
instructions at the end of each stage
you will have discussion prompts in a
type form so please first fill out your
form by yourself
and once you've finished it discuss your
answers in your breakout group
this is to
benefit from the principle of brainstorm
first
edit later
so better to do brainstorming by
yourself and then bringing it together
to talk to each other later
when each stage is complete you'll
receive a code word that you can put at
the end of your display name on zoom
so that the instructions will be in the
form and when you get there you'll be
able to see what to do
at the end of each stage we'll rejoin
the main session together
you can either rejoin on your own when
you're done discussing or
or there will be a time limit on each
stage so i'll bring everybody back
when you have a few minutes left i'll
send a message with the form url in case
you didn't get that far in your quest
with your group and you'll still have a
chance to reflect and come back to
discuss your answers with your team
at that point
so
during this
time
um we have
zoom as a way
to chat to each other so i've seen some
chats in here to help me know how my
audio is doing earlier
we
also have a slack channel so you can
reach out that way as well and when
you're in your
breakout rooms
you
will also be able to ask for help
i will also be posting instructions on
the slack channel just in case you miss
what's on my screen so once you've left
into your breakout room you won't be
able to see the
instructions for each stage so you can
check the slack channel if you need to
find out what they are
now for what you're expected to do
because this quest is highly interactive
and you're going to be working in
breakout rooms i have to put one rule on
it that's a little inconvenient
but i hope you'll work with me
on this if you stay with us and join the
quest please stay till the end of the
session
that's about an hour in let's say 43
minutes from now
otherwise your group will be down a
teammate and that's just not fair to
your teammates
so if you can't stay to the end of this
session
please watch the video online the
materials will be available for the next
month
and to have the full interactive
experience bring a friend to do it with
you i encourage you to do so
when you get into your groups
at least one person
per group should have a proper computer
to run the quest on
that's
not a phone or if you're joining us from
a tablet or something like that you will
be able to follow along because you can
screen share in your breakout groups
but at least one person needs to
actually be able to run the code
so let me know when you're in your
breakout groups as soon as you can
if you don't your group doesn't meet
this requirement so that i can rearrange
the groups
and finally be generous to each other
and follow the pi data global code of
conduct
so throughout the quest i already
mentioned it a little bit here are some
of the ways you can get help
first off you're not alone it's
interactive ask your neighbor ask
the people in your group do it together
even
i'll jump around from different groups
to check on how things are going you can
ask for help by zoom i'll pop it by as
quickly as i can you can reach out
through the slack channel
remember
we're all in this together so keep up
the communication let me know how it's
going if i'm having any difficulties and
you can't hear me or you can't see
something or something's confusing let
me know so that we can all have the best
possible experience together
and now for those of you who need to
come back and do this later this is a
time where you can sign off thank you so
much for coming i look forward to
hearing how your quest goes
at a later time
for those who are staying
um
please put in the chat any questions
that you might have i'll take any right
now
um
yes thank you red event and uh we'll be
about to start our quest
all right
it looks like we're down a few people so
now
it's time
to
meet your neighbors
so now i'm going to put you guys into
breakup groups
and what i'd like for you to do is to
answer a few questions we'll give you a
couple minutes just to introduce
yourselves
let's hear where you're coming from
today and something that you're hoping
to take away from this tutorial and
finally
uh just do a quick check in your group
to make sure that at least one person
is able to run everything that we're
doing today and
if so and
are they willing to share their screen
just the live just call issues we talked
about right before
and that's it let's get into our groups
welcome back
see all sorts of spaces popping back in
here
good to see you
now that you've met your neighbors we
are
about
to begin
so the first star to start of any quest
is to try to figure out where to
start
we're gonna
start off really gently today we're
gonna start off with the first
two things that are important for
reproducibility that
these days are pretty standard and
almost default we don't have to remember
it all the time
um
that is
readmes
and
licenses so to introduce you to your
quest
um i'm gonna send you to
a notebook in fact
because that's where we're gonna it's
easier to keep in the flow by using it
in notebook and i'm actually gonna ask
you to start by viewing it
from your browser don't actually even
try to run jupyter notebook in your
environment don't even try to do that
don't complicate issues we're going to
start super gently just hit up this link
now
i didn't hear of any issues with the
breakout room sounds like everybody has
what they need to get started so i'm
going to send you guys back now and you
get you can all tackle the first stage
of
this quest
and here we go
all right
it looks like
we still have people in
no we're good
are we all back i think so
so
um now that we've started you've got
someone in your group who made it
through um gotcha the first type form uh
that is great
now i'm gonna send you back to the very
end of that first notebook that you were
looking at you have one more instruction
we're gonna
do this just for practice for figuring
out how to find our way around uh this
challenge of
basically going through the steps of
um going
into breakout rooms
doing something filling out a form
coming back and changing your name so i
can tell how far you got
so that's what we're going to do next
the next one basically that's all you
have to it
and
next to the readme or maybe more
important than the readme is your
license file so
let's continue on to stage two
of the quest just right at the end of
that notebook that you started with with
the first link that we had head back up
there and make your way through to the
bottom
and i'll see you guys
soon
um yeah i needed welcome back
that was quick quick quick quick
practice on what these
stage quests look like so you're gonna
go down have an instruction do something
probably involves a little bit of
reading
um
follow there will be
some either quest tasks along the way
that you need to go to it'll say your
next task your quest
task or something like that and at the
end of those tasks there will be a type
form and once you fill that out you will
know you're at the end of that stage of
the quest
and i'll know that you're done it
because you'll have changed your display
name on zoom as well
so
continuing on
to the next question where
do i
go next
have you ever sat down at your keyword
to work on a project and wondered where
did i leave off what needs to get done
again where do i find that again
if so this stage of the quest is for you
we're going to go through
again some pretty straightforward issues
with generally conventional solutions
um
but some of it can be a little bit
tricky sometimes this is more like again
a reminder before we get into the
nitty-gritty of some of the more um
some of the some of the other
other harder to think about
ideas
um
some of the things are like you lost
your work you don't know where to find
your files
um anyone had a computer die and take
all their work with them
i definitely have
uh the other one that comes with this is
just get night burst so say you're doing
your job you are using git to control
everything and you're checking things in
and you're working with other people and
then
it just turns into a giant snot ball of
a mess and you have to figure out where
things were
and what you did and why you have this
really gnarly merge conflict
a lot of times that comes down to
underlying get workflow issues between
you and your collaborators
so this section is just basically about
those kinds of ideas
about having a way to keep your project
organized by default having workflows
that you use between you and the people
you're working with that you know you're
working with
leaving breadcrumbs behind yourself so
you can fight so you don't have to have
a working memory i certainly don't
sometimes with two small children
and
some of our recommendations on just how
to use a collaborative get in github
workflow
um this stage again is a pretty short
one we're gonna
it's mostly reading so if you don't have
your
machine running for this one that's okay
you should be able to follow along just
from
just from github
um
and here we go
here's where you go next
and
i will post that link in slack
and send you to the
breakout rooms
see you soon
and welcome back
welcome welcome
um
the next stage is where things start to
get
a little more interesting we are going
to start dealing with installation and
some of you have already had issues with
this by even trying to worry about conda
to start with
um
but so far someone in each group has
working
con condo everything so we can continue
on our quest
let's talk about what do i need to
install
this is
if there's one time saver one
reproducibility thing you take away from
this it's how to manage your environment
better now i personally like to use
conda so we're going to use that in this
example partly because it handles not
just python dependencies but a whole
host of other ones but
no
package or environment manager is
perfect they all have their gotchas so
some of these things are ways that we
use to make using conda better
so here we go
what are some of the issues
first off there might be no environment
instructions like this would be the
equivalent of like just
getting a notebook off the internet and
starting to run it and seeing what
happens
um without any documentation anything to
tell you
what you're supposed to do for your
environment
there is the constant issue and maybe my
biggest reproducibility personally that
experience in my workflow is if i work
on something in the past
and i come back to it in the future say
six months or a year later can i even
run the code anymore do i have a
memory
of what environment i use what packages
i need especially as things upgrade and
move on in life
and things get deprecated how do i go
back and use that and get back to what i
need to make my code work
another one is just the impossible
environment
this is what one of the reasons i love
conda is that it actually tries to
resolve my impossible environments and
tell me it so that if i smash something
with pip i
i know it and i can go back and i can
fix it
um
and
i don't know about you but when i first
started using conda i started with
monolithic condo environments i had
condo environments with not great names
like data science or
python 37
or maybe not python c7 this was back in
the day but you know you get the idea
python 2
python 3
and inevitably that causes all sorts of
distress
and if you've ever experienced
that i'm sure you know exactly what i'm
talking about
so here are a few
quick
principles and if you want to go ahead
and deeper dive on to this particular
issue i highly recommend
shell wooding's talk
on thursday
where he talks a lot about how to manage
environments and use make to do this
better
but we're going to actually experience
that we're going to experience that
workflow right now together
so
we're going to use a make file we're
going to use conda so that we have
exactly one or at least one if you want
developer environments as well virtual
environment for repo you want to use
lock files which help you
pin down your versions but still give
you the flexibility to upgrade when you
need to so you can roll back if you've
checked in your log files to what you
did in the past but you can also move
forward because you don't want to be
stuck running
running
old pandas or python 2 forever
and
of course check in your environment
creation instructions now in this
particular
tutorial we're skipping get unless you
feel up to the challenge
um just because that makes things take a
lot
longer that's a bonus challenge for
another day if you're up for it you can
check in things at the end of every
stage that would be great you'll get a
bonus at the very end but don't waste
your time doing that because we need to
keep things moving along so if you have
time go for it if not
that can be a bonus challenge that you
do at the end of everything
and now that we're used to how to how
this works i'm going to send you off to
your next challenge notebook you can
start in the browser that's the easiest
way to do it but there will be a point
where you do have to drop down and you
should drop down to make your
environment
um so now we're on to notebook number
three
i'll send you all back to your breakout
rooms check on how you're doing and i'll
see you soon
welcome welcome welcome welcome back
looks like we have everyone back so
let's move on in fact
we are gonna do something because we're
almost out of time
um we're gonna skip to the very end and
congratulations
[Laughter]
congratulations to everyone for
completing these first three stages of
the reproducibility
challenge the
easy data quest for reproducibility um
this
all went pretty much exactly as expected
um and i hope that i've teased and wet
your appetite enough that you'll want to
continue to
finish this challenge through the next
bits on your own
so so far just to remind you what have
we done we've done
where do i start
read me and license actually tell people
what you're gonna do and give them good
instructions
and put a license on it not putting a
license on it it's kind of like
leaving an empty lot with nothing on it
and hoping that people find their way
around rather than putting out a welcome
back or if you really don't want them
there let them know put up your no
trespassing sign just do it
where to go next
this is a couple things we talked about
today or happened in the tutorial where
just having a project organization
having a place to put things having a
place to find things being able to find
your way around when
your future you is looking for something
or when someone else is looking for
something
and we started to get familiar with
using automated workflows using make
with the nice auto documenting make
file next up was installation and i'm so
glad we got through the stage because
again as i said if there's nothing else
to change
start
making your environments more
reproducible
and
you can use conda and make to do it
uh so may create your environments and
use an environment.yaml file to keep
things
um
up to date
so your memory doesn't have to use it
and so that you can also make delete
your environment and start again from
scratch without any issue
now what do you have in store still
you have
to continue on your quest you can
learn about where to find
data and how to create data set recipes
so that when you want to use a data set
you can just data set dot load it
by name
and the data set
is
recreated from the raw data
and cached if necessary so that you can
just be confident that you're doing
things with the right data and
that it is the data that you expect it
to be so one of the tricks there is to
keep your metadata with your data and
that all happens with dataset.load
that's
that's the next stage
the
stage after that
is
does it work as expected
and so in this repo we have a make test
so by the time you get to the end of
this stage you should be able to write
type make tests and everything will work
if you type make test right now things
will be broken that's intentional that's
part of your quest
and finally at the end of the day
what's the point
i love jupiter notebooks
i use them all the time
especially for storytelling because they
help the purpose shine through
but often when i'm using it for
exploratory work or just trying to get
started i have all sorts of grungy
functions in there that i don't really
need to stay there so
there's this nice element that you might
have noticed in your condo environment
diamond file that says pip
under the pip install line there's a
dash e dot
and that gives you your editable source
module now i won't spoil the fun
but if you go ahead and complete that
part you'll learn how to
take
code out of your notebook in a way that
you can constantly keep editing and
reusing it while you're in your notebook
and test it better too
and if you want to give easy data a try
if you want to learn more about how to
do this stuff if you want to use easy
data to create your own reproducible
repos or even just your own reproducible
environments the instructions for
getting started with
easy data can be found
on the readme
at github.com hackalog slash easy data
there's lots more on reproducibility
there if you check it out and i will
update this tutorial with more
references
after this
and i would be remiss to end
without
giving a few
thanks for this
at first i want to say thanks to the
tech institute for math and computing
for sponsoring so much of the work on
easy data and for the data scientists
there that we get to collaborate with
who inspired many of these workflows
speaking of people i collaborated with
there were alpha testers who tried out
some very rough and sketchy versions of
this tutorial to start with and you know
if you are so thank you
and i'd also like to thank all the
projects whose work we've built on over
the years cookie cutter data science for
example and
uh while we didn't get there if you do
notebooks four and five i stole an
example from umap
uh especially thanks to shell wooding
who is
done most of
well my easy collaborator but also
happens to be my husband and who is
currently taking care of the kids so i
don't have to be watching them right now
so thank you
and last
i would like to express our things and
then
ask you to join me in taking a moment to
appreciate the amazing pi data global
conference that we've just experienced
i'd like you to encourage you to share
something in the chat or on slack that
you've appreciated about the conference
from the past few days
and before i go
i want you to know
that
i'm
here and this is not just hello and
goodbye but hopefully also see you again
soon i'll be around slack and afterwards
if you want to have a chat or any
further questions and you can find me on
github
um
i'm happy to chat about all things
reproducibility
and
really anything else i'm interested in
i want to remind you
one last thing
reproducibility isn't just for science
it's about being a better collaborator
with your colleagues with your
co-workers your eventual replacements
and your future self
make it easy for yourself bake
reproducibility into your workflows your
neighbors and your future self
will
thank you
[Music]
and as the last stage
there's something i really like to do at
the end of things
and that is what i'll call a ruckus
goodbye so i would like for you all to
join me at the very end of this and say
goodbye by unmuting yourself
and all at once we will say goodbye and
we will leave this room all right
[Music]
so
one
two three
goodbye